bienvenue dans envies de lecture en
compagnie de nathalie veulent évidemment
bonjour attriste bonjour alors nous
allons prendre un peu de temps pour
parler d'un roman qui nous a bouleversés
et qui est à la fois très émouvant à la
fois aussi terrifiant par l'histoire
avec un grand h qu'il raconte c'est le
roman de jeanne trung ceux qui sont
restés là bas qui est publié chez
gallimard bonjour et merci d'être venus
jusqu'ici avait avec nous peut-être
peut-être date et vous présenter en
quelques mots j'aime trucks avec grand
plaisir bonjour jeune trio où nous
sommes ravi ravi de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui alors vous êtes écrivain
auteur de plusieurs nouvelles des romans
et votre dernier roman qui s'intitule
ceux qui sont restés là-bas parution
gallimard alors c'est vrai patrice le
disais à l'instant c'est un livre qui
est très fort qui est bouleversant qui
est porté par cette écriture remarquable
ya vraiment ne voit la vôtre qui nous
tient tout au long de cette terrible
plonger dans le cambodge est bien le
cambodge des khmers rouges rouges alors
le livre se passeront en 1970 on a
peut-être un peu resituer la période
historique c'est la troisième des quatre
années d'enfer au fond que que ville
le cambodge sous sur l'enfer mer rouge
peut-être peut-être la plus terrible
d'ailleurs de ces zones et parce que mon
manque de douilles à on avait les
massacres les règlements de compte
la violence et et d'absolu mans partout
c'est ce que vous appelez au grand bond
en arrière info dudu du cambodge
alors avant d'aller plus loin est
peut-être de parler durement peut-être
vous resituer cette période c'est à dire
que paul côte est arrivé au pouvoir en
75 là où nous sommes 78 qu'est-ce qui se
passe historiquement effectivement donc
en 75 polpot et des communistes ont pris
le pouvoir et sont rentrés à phnom penh
ils ont évacué toute la population de la
capitale vers
les campagne cambodgienne et où se
trouve donc les camps et les gens ont dû
vivre comme des paysans en fait donc la
première année ça s'est passé de manière
plutôt pas trop difficile puisqu'il y
avait encore à manger il y avait encore
les greniers qui était plein et puis
petit à petit ça s'est vite d'élite et
puisque la famine est arrivé parce que
évidemment tous ces gens de villes ne
savais pas du tout cultiver ne savais
pas du tout faire un travail de deux
paysans le principe c'est et d'éradiquer
rendre d'enlever les modèles et des
intellectuels les eaux des populations
des villes de faire un peuple de paysans
sao paulo oui c'était tout à fait ça
c'est à dire que évidemment les gens de
villes étaient les gens qui étaient des
bourgeois des capitalistes dont qu'ils
avaient déjà des gènes corrompu et donc
c'était de faire un nouveau peuple un
peuple pur de tout de tout désir
finalement d'enrichissement ou de de
capitalisation enfin et pour ça on les
met à la campagne et on les met au
travail
à la terre en fait simplement vous
imaginez bien si du jour au lendemain on
demandait aux parisiens d'aller à la
campagne
il serait pas utilisé une pioche ou un
râteau enfin et donc du coup la
production agricole a chuté de manière
drastique et les gens évidemment ont été
massacrées avec des machettes mais la
plupart des gens sont morts quand même
de faim et de maladies causées par un
état enfin un état de fragilité extrême
du corps et donc voilà c'est la limite
après enfin voilà donc 78 ça a été
l'année la plus difficile puisqu'ils
n'avaient strictement plus rien à manger
et est d'ailleurs polpot rééquilibrer un
petit peu l'offre et la demande si je
peux lui dire en tuant des gens puisque
s'il n'y a pas de manger vous tuer les
gens il ya moins de bouches à nourrir
donc c'est l'année où des phénomènes de
cannibalisme se sont multipliées par
exemple les gens ont même commencé à
manger leurs excréments enfin voila
c'était une situation terrible est parce
qu il imaginable a d'ailleurs quand on
lit des romans il ya des situations qui
sont ses vrais que on n'imagine pas un
instant que ça n'est pas cette situation
extrême et puis voilà et puis en fait
polpot a commencé à massacrer
massivement des vietnamiens parce qu'il
y avait énormément de vietnamiens au
cambodge et cause de la guerre non pas
pour pas forcément à cause de la guerre
non non c'était pas du tout à cause de
la guerre c'est en fait auparavant fait
savoir que c'était l'indochine
oui et l'indochine enfin le cambodge
faisait partie de l'indochine le vietnam
aussi donc en fait des liens il y avait
des liens il y avait il y avait beaucoup
de fonctionnaires vietnamiens au
cambodge
là c'était une volonté des français en
fait parce que les vietnamiens parler
mieux le français maîtriser mieux le
français donc du coup été beaucoup plus
dans l'administration française qu'il y
avait toute cette population qui était
là et puis les vietnamiens de tout temps
ont toujours été aucun match les
frontières a été quand même assez fou à
l'époque il y avait beaucoup de
possibilité de passer d'un pays à
l'autre et donc polpot a voulu récupérer
aussi une zone qui était embauchée à
chrome est assise à la suite de ça en
fait les trous vietnamiens sont rentrés
dans le cambodge et ils ont lu libérer
les camps c'est là que le roman va
commencer parce que c'est ça qui est
très original je trouve dans votre livre
parce que vous allez traiter cette
période pour aider beaucoup moins
l'histoire du génocide cambodgien c'est
la libération des camps est là et c'est
vraiment une force voilà on dit de la
vague ce formidable et c'est terminé et
la force deuxième force de votre roman
c'est de montrer avec une précision
incroyable que voilà cette libération
n'en est pas une
bien au contraire on va entrer dans une
période terrible qui commence pour votre
narrateur narrant que c'est un enfant de
6 7 ans et il fuit avec sa mère et des
milliers de rescapés donc vers la
thaïlande
alors ce qu'on a envie de savoir eh bien
c'est pourquoi vous avez choisi
et bien un enfant pourra compter cet
exode est lé danger constant qu'elle
doit faire face
c'est bien ceux qui tentent de fuir la
mort effectivement là si je veux c'est
une situation extrêmement cruelle parce
que effectivement les gens étaient
pleins d'espoir plein de le soulagement
de pouvoir enfin quitter les camps et
tout le monde a cherché évidemment à se
mettre à l'abri en partant dans à
l'étranger ont pas rester dans le pays
parce que d'abord il s'était il était
pas forcément très informés on ne savait
pas du tout ce qui allait se passer
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas effectivement
le recul historique qu'on a aujourd'hui
est donc la première des choses c'est se
mettre à l'abri et se mettre à l'abri
c'est partir quitter le pays et donc du
kunar ans et sa maman effectivement fui
vers la thaïlande en pensant trouver
cette ruche qui espérait tant et c'est
là où la deuxième tragédie arrive et et
c'est ce qui fait aussi la toute la
cruauté de la destinée humaine est ce
qu'il traverse la jungle
ils sont pris également des passeurs
charognards
les lieux ont plu sur ma soeur on peut
se perdre les animaux dangereux le la
vie dans nadja plus les désarmer plus
les gens qui tuent plus est c'est enfin
tf1
justement dans le soleil nathalie parler
du jeune narrateur d'un roman vous même
vous êtes vous êtes né aux compotes
donc on aurait pu s'attendre aussi à ce
que vous choisissiez le le récit où le
laissez vous avez choisi le roman et je
me demande si une des raisons mais vous
allez bleus le dit c'est parce que
peut-être avec le roman on peut
peut-être plus dire l'indicible si je
peux dire oui c'est moi mon but c'était
de pas de faire un essai j'adore ça
c'était c'était quasiment hors de
question évidemment à l'occasion
justement d'interviews esterra laisser
vient en fait c'est à dire la réflexion
c'est tout ça voilà la raisonner c'était
revient forcément mais on sait que ce
que je voulais absolument faire et que
le roman permet c'est de se mettre à
l'intérieur des personnages et à
l'intérieur de cette souffrance-là parce
que la difficulté ce camp c'est ce qu'on
nomme l'indicible c'est au fond
c'est au fond la véritable souffrance
que les gens ont traversé et permettre
en fait aux lecteurs de s'identifier un
petit peu à cette souffrance
c'est vrai quand on touche mieux
l'inhumanité la violence l'absurdité ou
faux cette situation je pense avec un
roman que peut-être avec un récit est
toujours un peu où il ya toujours un peu
de distance évidemment oui
et puis c'est un certain rapport aux
mots aussi parce que par exemple dans si
on fait un essai sur la famine sous
polpot ce conte son essai offert c'est
par exemple de dire voilà ils ont ils
ont souffert de la soif ils ont souffert
de la fin mais on ne peut pas accéder à
la dimension vécu de ces mots c'est à
dire qu'en réalité la faim et la soif
prenez voilà prennent des dimensions
métaphysique
dans ce contexte là dans la mesure où
quand vous avez faim et vous savez pas
si dans une minute donc dans une demi
journée vous allez mourir à cause de ça
ça change complètement l'acception de ce
mot fin parce que ça veut dire aussi que
vous êtes prêts à tuer peut-être votre
voisin pour prendre sa nourriture
vous avez des dilemmes métaphysique est
ce que à qui je donne le dernier morceau
de nourriture c'est à dire est ce que je
me donne à ma fille est ce que je le
donne à mon fils c'est comme le oui il
ya une scène magnifique et la mère du
héros donne son sein un bébé qui va
mourir quoi et c'est vrai que et oui est
ce qu'il faut le faire par le fait ce
qu'il veut se sauver soi-même c'est vrai
que l'homme touche la réalité de cette
horreur quoi et je pense que voilà je
n'aurais pas pu traduire ça avec l'essai
en fait et je dirais aussi parce que
j'ai trouvé vraiment important dans ce
livre peut-être dans une époque
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans l'auto
fiction en permanence des versements de
ce soir je trouve que dans votre livre
vous faites pas un témoignage mais un
roman on y lit à je ne sais pas si on le
sent là dans cette conversation vraiment
une grande pudeur c'est un cri les
choses sont dites avec force mais il ya
aussi cette pudeur que le roman permet
il sort dans nos sociétés c'est rare
aujourd'hui je trouve mais c'est un
rapport chacun enfin chaque auteur a un
rapport à la nature différente
c'est vrai que la difficulté dans un
récit tel que celui là c'est de ne pas
prendre la place des autres et donc si
vous voulez faire sentir ce que tous ces
gens ont traversé cette souffrance il
faut que cette souffrance puissent
s'exprimer en fait au delà même des
êtres qui les vivent
et évidemment le lait forcée de se
retirer parce que bon et puis je vois là
cet indicible ne peut pas tellement se
traduire aussi par des mots je pense
j'ai réussi à faire quelque chose mais
pas forcément à faire réellement ce que
j'ai voulu mais voilà c'est un jeu pensé
avec ce film exceptionnel livre alors
justement revenir sur votre narrateur
nhà rông ce petit garçon qui sait zoo
s'interroger sur le sens de la ville
dans cet enfer que je vous cite je le
cite qu'était la vie pour un enfant mon
âge pourquoi je suis né à ce moment là
je ne croyais ni en avignon la mort mot
vivre mourir ça n'existait pas alors on
a envie de vous demander
jeanne truong commencé veille chez un
enfant de cet âge la conscience du bien
et du mal
finalement ça c'est une grande question
je pense pas avoir totalement la réponse
d'abord je pense que la conscience
morale ne s'éveille pas malheureusement
chez tous les enfants
il ya des enfants qui ont été trop
abîmée notamment ceux qui ont été
complètement encadrés par l'idéologie de
polpot et encadrer de manière très mal
parce que c'est également ce sont des
gamins
ce sont des gamins soldats de pol pot 3
les soldats via raisonnée c'est le savez
les 120 et y compris vous les les
on va dire les officiers 1 sont souvent
des jeunes ils ont à peine 18 ans 19 ans
donc ça aussi c'est un contexte très
particulier qu'on oublie souvent quand
on parle du cambodge
voilà et donc il ya ces enfants qui sont
abîmés mais par ailleurs les victimes
enfants sont aussi abîmé
parce qu'on les a extrait en fait de
l'éducation de leurs parents et ils sont
mis dans une des cellules à part et donc
ils n'ont pas vécu avec l'amour de leurs
parents en est un et c'est justement ces
enfants là malheureusement c'est très
difficile pour eux ensuite d'avoir
un sens de l'altérité en revanche vous
avez des enfants et c'est là où
l'atavisme peut-être à un effet c'est à
dire que vous avez des enfants qui sont
comme narrant d'emblée on cette
compassion pour les autres et ça on peut
pas trop bien expliqué en fait c'est
certainement des traditions très
anciennes des familles et puis il ya
aussi des disparités au sein même des
familles dont c'est une question assez
difficile en fait mais j'ai lancé
d'ailleurs un peu différente un le
comportement un oui bien sûr c'est ça la
mer à l'est figé comme ça dans non dans
sa souffrance dont se souvenir qu'à là
parce qu'elle a perdu son mari et sa
fille et vous être aussi des on a
l'impression que yahia fins que vous
allez vous le montrer aussi cette
différence entre l'enfant et l'adulte
face à l'expérience génocidaire qui
existent peut-être oui c'est en tout cas
de mon point de vue et de mon expérience
vécue
il y a une grande grande différence
entre les adultes et les enfants les
adultes eux ont déjà eu un univers avant
polpot évidemment qui était un univers
du coût comparé à celui de polpot
complètement paradisiaques et ils ont
cette référence qui les écrasent d'une
certaine manière
tandis qu'un enfant comme
narrant qui a 6 ans donc qui qui n'est
pas encore tout à fait face honey lui il
est né dans les camps il a grandi dans
les camps biocodex or il n'a connu que
c'est en fait je n'ai pas eu d'enfance
ou presque alors mais en même temps là
je dirais que s'il n'a pas eu d'enfance
cette enveloppe est cette enfant cela
c'est sa réalité donc comme n'importe
qui je pense quand vous êtes jetés dans
un certain environnement vous fait avec
et puis vous jouez avec l'enfant il a
comme cette plasticité là et ce qui fait
que ils voient les choses de manière
différente des adultes en revanche la
mer représente un peu tout le peuple
cambodgien hébétés par cette catastrophe
et il n'a pas les ressorts
malheureusement elle en tout cas n'a pas
les ressorts de pour pour réagir et pour
même pour je dirais même le minimum pour
sauver son propre enfant âgé il ya une
chose qui est un pur passionnante aussi
dans ce livre que j'écris c'est à dire
au début c'est au fond comment il une
greffe de deux d'idéologie sur la
culture une culture et deux choses
totalement étranger vous écrivait
d'ailleurs nous sommes nous sommes
vraiment mort pour des mouches ne vont
même pas compris et ses mots et c'était
marxisme prolétariat parti communiste
est évidemment cette greffe ne peut pas
prendre
et est-ce que c'est elle qui plonge le
pays dans cette folie dans les camps par
exemple vous raconter il était interdire
d'avoir des émotions interdit de manger
des fruits de dd des arbres un homme a
été tué pour avoir chanté enfin cette
folie c'est ça est-ce qu'elle vient de
cette au fond de cette grève qui ne
pouvait pas prendre entre des notions
comme le communisme
le marxisme et puis la culture moi je
pense que effectivement le l'expérience
de paul potts et une expérience qui est
là une forme de prolongement aussi de
l'expérience coloniale dans la mesure où
en fait polpot a tout fait pour couper
les êtres de de leurs racines naturelles
parce que les hommes évidemment ou une
sensibilité ont des émotions ont dépensé
et il n'y a que la force et la violence
pour empêcher un homme finalement de se
couper de tout ça c'est une forme de
séparation de soi avec soi qu'à aussi
opérer le colonialisme certaine manière
parce que évidemment à la base qu'est ce
que c'est que une colonie c'est un
régime qui prive le peuple le peuple du
sol le peuple du théâtre du territoire
de de son propre poids politique
déjà ça et puis la colonisation
française a cette particularité de
vouloir aussi enlevé la culture
originelle aux peuples colonisés en
faisant enfin évidemment voulu imposer
d'autres cultures
voilà comme obligeant les gens étaient
très français meilleure vision de la
colonisation
d'ailleurs pardon mais où le fait de
dire un personnage à un moment parce
qu'un journaliste qui arrivent et qui
dit c'est quand même c'est quand même
très étonnant parce que vous êtes un
peuple d'où
gentil et sait comment comment cette
tragédie at-elle pu se produire et le
personnage à qui dit ça mais lui répond
mais est-ce que vous pensez que polpot
aurait existé sans la colonisation et
sans la guerre du vietnam au 1
c'est vrai que c'est on a tendance à
expliquer les jeunes au cid par la
nature des races ça c'est une idée que
je condamne totalement
évidemment une telle catastrophe ne peut
s'expliquer que par aussi des parts and
très objectif par les enchaînements de
l'histoire tout à fait et évidemment les
gens qui disent ça c'est aussi pour ne
pas endosser la responsabilité
historique oui c'est beaucoup voilà vous
êtes comme ça voilà exactement
donc moi s'agit bien entendu énormément
et oui bien sûr bien sûr parce que s est
vrai que nous avons une apparence gentil
toiser éducation voilà et donc on ne
comprend pas cette barbarie
est ce donc ça veut bien dire que ça n'a
rien à voir avec voilà le comportement
d'un peuple coincé oui et alors au coeur
de votre livre bien sûr il ya le silence
le silence de la mer on l'a dit à
l'instant et puis celui de l'enfant
narrant la mer e et celui de l'enfant
narang qui devient muet après
l'assassinât de son père et de sa soeur
alors dès les premières lignes de votre
livre vous abordé de façon extrêmement
subtil en question qui est très complexe
c'est celle de la culpabilité et celle
du point que porte et bien ceux qui ont
survécu
ils en ont honte et pourtant ils sont
eux aussi victimes de cette tragédie le
clip d'ailleurs s'intitule ceux qui sont
restés là bas et donc il ya aussi ceux
qui ne sont pas restés là bas qu'ils
vivent est ce drame alors comment se
reconstruit lorsqu'on en a réchappé et
commande sur monte dans les fagnes lé
silence qui règne et cette période de
l'histoire qui je crois est resté assez
longtemps tabou quand même entre les
deux états unien d'ailleurs ce livre a
pris presque 40 ans pour ce faire je
pense que c'est un peu sa fin c'est
cette durée là un minimum pour dénouer
les la parole en fête
alors ce silence cette culpabilité c'est
s'explique aussi par le fait que les
gens qui on aurait échappé pense qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit de parler puisque ne
sont pas morts et que au fond ils n'ont
pas vécu pire est donc parler à la place
des morses et c'est abject d'une
certaine manière
donc on peut comprendre ce poids
et qui du coup est peut-être ressenti
comme un tabou pour les générations
d'après s'est passé est arrivé pour le
pour l'est les hawks ont sorti des camps
nazis
ils ont mis un temps assez long avant de
parler aussi parce qu'on voulait pas les
entendre avoir droit de parler tout de
suite enfin par rapport à ce qui est des
morts mais moi je pense que oui le c'est
plutôt un silence qui vient de soi plus
que un silence imposé par les autres
parce que on pourrait aussi
il aurait pu aussi écrire en khmer les
livres donc mais ça n'a pas été fait
parce que je pense que cette culpabilité
est vraiment quelque chose de difficile
à surmonter
moi même enfant je suis rentré dans le
silence de mes parents aussi
et il y avait alors il y avait il y
avait plusieurs raisons
dans la persistance de ses silences par
exemple ma grand mère elle qui a qui a
perdu trois fils donc qui n'a pas
pardonné
elle ne voulait pas elle disait très
explicitement elle voulait pas accabler
les générations ça à venir elle ne
voulait pas que les générations
suivantes
sache que l'être humain a pu aller aussi
loin
cc et elle voulait préserver préserver
leur optimiste au fond parce que ça
c'est une ce qu'on a vécu là bas c'est
une ce quelque chose d'indicible mais
surtout sur la cruauté humaine sur la
nature humaine et ça je crois que elle
ne voulait pas elle ne voulait pas fait
bien les générations c'est ce qu'elle
disait explicitement et voilà il ya une
forme de reconstruction sur les procès
évidemment qu'ils peuvent
être intentées aux responsables de ces
génocides il est relativement peu pol
pot dont il a disparu sans être jugé il
duch qui était le gardien le coup tijd
et des prisons qui était qui était
condamné il ya deux dignitaires je crois
aussi maires qui ont été jugés en 2018
ou font assez peu de procès oui le moi
j'ai vu le procès de loin de la france
donc je n'étais pas sur place mais
j'avais l'impression d'assister plus un
simulacre pour vous tous vous dire et
puis ces dignitaires qui sont enfin dits
knitter ces génocidaires qui sont venus
avec des lunettes de soleil c'était un
peu bizarre comme quand mise en scène
tout même
mais avait quelque chose d'une mascarade
il est resté un procès un peu aussi pour
pays pauvres un peu j'avais cette
impression là quand même et et puis bon
il était de mettre la justice là dedans
enfin après voilà elle puisse aider les
gens c'était haché et au fond pour moi
même s'ils ont la même défense c'est à
dire on a bouilli aux ordres c'est
toujours la défense des des criminels
chez les nazis absolument maman fait
tout lui n'a pas été un décisionnaire
comme nokia ou que son banc mais j'avais
quelques temps c'est un exécutant malgré
tout il l'avait ça toute sa
responsabilité dans cette affaire
donc bon nous on est on est quand même
content qu'il y ait quelque chose qui
soit formalisée autour de ça et alors
c'est vrai que c'est assez spécifique
parce que là on s'est demandé qui ont
qui ont jugé comment punir les les
responsables et avec au cambodge
une personne sur cinq assassiné
peut-être juste on va avant de conclure
comment on se reconstruit à l'échelle de
la nation la réconciliation nationale au
cambodge
comment elle c'est là puissent opérer
alors qu alors c'est une question un peu
difficile pour moi parce que je n'habite
pas au cambodge je ne suis pas sur le
terrain
ce que je sais c'est que peut-être je
sais pas peut-être que le bouddhisme
c'est une forme de réponse pour pour les
cambodgiens
cette histoire est comment dirais-je
cette notion de karma au fond peut-être
permet psychologiquement aux gens de
cohabiter avec les bourreaux par exemple
c'est à dire qu'on vit cette tragédie
comme une épreuve au fond d'eux pour
pour s'éveiller aussi à la conscience
morale à la une forme de compassion
aussi bon je sais tu sais lire une ces
questions un peu difficile pour moi
maintenant sûre en tout cas la
littérature prépare justement voilà on
est obligé de s'arrêter on aurait
conversé des heures encore le livre
s'appelle ceux qui sont restés là-bas
bravo d'avoir eu la force aussi décrire
ce superbe roman
merci beaucoup jamais très bon lui merci
merci beaucoup
[Musique]